so for those of you have just joined us
in chats we are playing daylights today
a procedurally generated survival horror
game which interestingly integrates with
the twitch chat so you guys can type
like commands to trigger things that
will happen in game so who typed in the
command to kill the street yeah who tied
that one cuz it worked well we're back
in but nothing has happened since then
we're still in this Asylum and I'm doing
around imagery fool you have too many
glue sticks you can never have too many
clothes sticks come on ya know Oh what's
going on the remnants will leave their
mark on you [ __ ] oh I better be seized
are gonna come I don't know me don't how
would you know that I can't move forward
oh whoa what have a nice weird I bet
someone made a heartbeat happened just
then you did someone you bosses chess is
like me I'll scream static light yeah
someone d-daddy one come on now who did
that they're gonna be a witchy sometime
yeah why do people keep saying oh did he
say that line already here they only had
the voice actors to do three different
vids right and it's procedurally
generated huh they couldn't pay her
enough hahahaha we got was cheap and
baby go one fears from from zareen
where'd you boo she's disappeared what's
in Joel what gateway you can't just say
these words and like cool walk I know
right I feel like I've been thrown into
the middle of something without really
understanding the context is I wonder if
I can activate yes oh it's all the [ __ ]
we picked up I think no it's not yeah
right I didn't pick up a teddy bear hey
did oh you picked him a story about it
today this nope Nerys lady I'm holding a
pair I'm disease okay what why am i
holding event can i know i don't know
why would you need this also how either
open door oh cool that was a bit weird
yeah like how are we gonna use glow
sticks no [ __ ] oh is that one of you
anytime something scary happens it's
gonna assume someone in the chat chicken
stick Yeager Bryant yeah I could see
them yeah yeah yeah except what's you
yeah ain't it more aggressive I hope you
want in July look at that map yeah well
oh cool glow stick thing I think they
got the beginning of each level
checkpoint thingy you're supposed to be
like a lot of stories Oh what the bowls
that was a bit scary I think she wanted
to play hide and seek damn it I
accidentally click through foster JG's
possible life it's very young um cheesy
I don't want to say
oh don't know if I come hang on okay
never mind can we climb these nope I
make some nerve parkinson they're just
too low for me to climb onto Jess can't
you see anybody feel like this is more
than three and the books surprisingly it
almost looks exactly the same we play a
lot of old horror games where you get
these sort of like issues where like the
graphics also good text is also great
this game came out three months ago fair
enough it's an indie game but you know
we see a lot of really amazing indie
games it's not like Sonic's used to have
bad everything else would live oh wait
what is your full damage I have super
legs are you here to enjoy the fine
integration of twitch into this lovely
game hmm this room looks very similar in
looks really similar to another room
where in that procedural generation whoa
so scary that's a bit creepy the witch
is coming she behind you my god Jess I
don't know I could eat him I think she's
behind you I don't know a Mary it's very
calming when you do that [ __ ] you guys
talking feet hi guys sagging feet you
Kipling so you can't see [ __ ] at all oh
there she is take it ah yeah [ __ ]
really oh [ __ ] I don't even know what to
do that yeah
she's smoking well I don't like a
running at ua that sucks my lost Flair
know if you guys just joining us this
girl won't stop asking if anybody's
there in a place where there's clearly
no humans I really want to pull the mat
but I don't think that I don't think
that oh my god I can't fake oh sweet the
sigil is here get on oh [ __ ] hello Sarah
what if I why do you want to play get
better Linda how God that was scary that
was [ __ ] scary Krishna 85 prism
should give them names not very nice
cool people numbers vision 9f they
should ream lined the process what's a
corporation that's not very consistent
oh here we go ok then all right she shat
let's play nice I'm not here to hurt you
haha I take that back don't interact
with anything without the maze amazed
design alerts from Tron oh good oh my
God we're fine with some reminisce oh
wow we hit the jackpot sure did ok danky
jangling Jose I've got my video deep I
fled her i fled oh whoa boulder man look
at all the blood that we're playing
screams oh no the Chaon mazes back I
can't see me wrong from hell hi no left
his blog oh [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah no
worries whatsoever sweet
come back yeah yeah drink I reckon we're
gonna rock there we go how'd you do that
I pulled the leaf on your clever thing
thank you my daddy says that too I don't
know why said that anyway Oh nervous
going that's real [ __ ] ass wit ditch
her know what I'm saying I can't see my
map anymore more bloodied up that she's
right behind me yeah yeah oh well what
good girl excellently [ __ ] you [ __ ]
haha good stuff oh it was our way back
up here we go hey bring a whole eat a
whole oh no I used a flare stop beating
yeah Mandy's GPS F so good ya reckon
can't learn how did you believe in in
johor a situation of the home GPS all
right six out of six let's go back and
claim our schedule for the lady finds us
some food she's obviously right behind
us is like hang on I gotta check my fire
[ __ ] off well the inconceivable NOT
unconcerned with master voice actor man
yes your render backpack I've been here
before plot twist this guy's probably
just chasing your round putting it down
the start of each area I like the
collecting aspect I like that you're
trying to find it did ya know if I can
use something here but not really sure
but why are you trying to tell me game
tell me dude if you're still in the
tutorial like seventy percent into your
game this is not ideal where is the bra
oh it's over there what the [ __ ] the
game is trying to make us move something
we're not even next to holy [ __ ] well
back yet bad baguette Oh Maggie I can't
go around as an invisible okay it must
be something to do the hose then
mysterious can why don't we light the
thing on fire it'll looks oh ya know
that gave us I'll leave it to Fleming
say oh yeah let's try that hey presto
I'm stuck oh ah geez um there was a
memory down the side if you want to do
that before you climb Oh perfect oh it's
not a remnant some random piece shows
they probably don't call them Brandon
pieces of [ __ ] in the development person
good thing Sarah's real fit like that
guy said that is the making that Kevin
and what brought up is that you can
sprint forever in this game oh really
yeah there's no sprint Vita it's just
like [ __ ] run I guess she's like a
marathon runner us something I know he
talking about yes again i can't i get i
get it
oh what oh [ __ ] I like hell with Blair I
didn't she see take so [ __ ] long to
get it out sure EULA oh hell yellow
alert holy crap buckets that was good
yes okay we have one left Novak we don't
know whether getting jiggy jjjjj citizen
I think it might be just exactly know
the total voice top 10 almost oh she
that's us has a rough future ahead of
her after her mother died giving birth
complications with restless baby the
blood um her name quit 13 witches who
were killed on mid island oh my god wow
it's only a plot twist if you believe
that you're somebody else not you never
knew who you were anyway run today like
run to daylight go reham running yeah oh
man there's so much daylight news Wanda
that's color like that well that's kind
of sweet that reminds me of a good king
was me Crichton now yeah it did actually
I thought the same thing Gryba man it
was a great game there I'd say it's a
soul of three yeah I love no surprise
that it's a three uh so that was
daylight everyone that was all of
daylight daylight from start to finish
one half hours you can also pick that up
if you're interested in playing that may
be like get a kick out of it with your
friends or something yeah on pc on steam
or on the ps4 as well just add one
person and now we're back next week with
another game and if you want to suggest
anything for that you can write tues or
I on our Twitter's Serena's @zt Holly
I'm at Jess McDonald or you can comment
on YouTube or games what we read them
also
I give us your feedback and let us know
what you think cool thank you very much
for joining us everyone see you next
week